yes my only cane to bex kandahar at zero
passes
yes but this block from prima bella to karen
a united states a rape to
benefit from the nobel peace prize
is to be invested with a mission,
that is to convey peace the
ideas closely wherever
possible europe has not been made we have
had war europe will not be made all at
once it will be made by concrete achievements
is this your initial bet messy
20 in europe  to samsung made that ten a
great china this is a serious problem in
april against watson great party
why did i kong reality we
wanted to make europe after the
second world war
vanessa beau fixed
the first common market
this first
supranational institution c  is europe
starting suny
and christmas tv happening to you as a
crucial factor is the term for
the economy to teach there because there
are some but it's still going back
you a little wonder what
europe was still there  50 years old
at the moment solidarity may be
a little weird under strain but
suddenly yes it's true that it may be
good to remember that we,
unlike
our parents grandparents, did not know Pierre
Bois  ladies every year
common european framework of europeans or
dizziness
this type of humor that fine is quick to
what was a sad sad this
gait of the rules of the game einstein wang
wang chao woman li hao new europe
features europe she is perfect for
we it is made for all the european countries
open our arms these countries
it's great it's our heart that
never spoke normal
me i can't a fiat adventure
may 1st 2004 i was with all those who
were emitted victory because  it was
a symbolic moment our return to
the community of peoples whose
poland is locked in its place
trish godman match point to the belgian
angelo diana in commando uniform
on against agen of split second
pretty becoming gr  ave i dreamed of it of a
cape town or of frost and morals
said santiago rosas
making the diet
the teacher must sit down
we can never remember enough how
much this peace now taking root there
it constituted a  revolution in
relation to a history dotted
over centuries of incessant conflict
dramatic bloody
the libero not